creating some podcast value bad
[ __ ] it's dirt wet Thursday the
23rd whatever the [ __ ] that is who gives
a [ __ ]
you're alive you're [ __ ] smoking dope
most importantly you're ready a sling
[ __ ] dick listen the song I'm gonna
die on the respectful Buffalo is you
wouldn't die by Rick James 78 put that
on right now on YouTube had some black
people with black people even Martin
Luther King popped up and said Jesus
you're on fire Rick
anyway the Church of what's happening
now is brought to you and I want to
welcome them cuz I [ __ ] love this
[ __ ] butcher box listen the big game is
right around the corner next week that
means you're gonna have a party which
means you're gonna have a bunch of
[ __ ] savages tearing through your
refrigerator eating up all your food
hopefully you'll have some class and you
won't feed these people [ __ ] that hummus
or a bowl of potato chips or veggie
plate because you're a [ __ ] savage
this year level your game the [ __ ] up
and give them butcher box you like Joey
what's butcher box butcher box is a
subscription service that sends you nine
to eleven pounds of high-quality
humanely raised organic meat every month
they ship it frozen and vacuum sealed so
it arrives as your door as fresh as a
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of the shower you
understand last night I had the [ __ ]
salmon and my wife made like a little
capable lemon sauce on top man it was
[ __ ] tremendous she took out two
steaks tonight to take a look at I'm
gonna give him Lee a couple burgers they
sent this listen it is sensational I'm
usually not big on these food services
but lately with the meat [ __ ] and you
gotta take care of yourself with the
organic what I'm gonna do is this
thinking they got free-range chicken
heritage pork walk caught salmon
grass-fed beef but they got something at
all you [ __ ] love you ready
since I'm talking about Buffalo you
ready wait
so right now butcher box has a special
offer
Lee you might as well write it down
three wings for
of your subscription that's three pounds
of wings and every box you order forever
for free plus you get 20 bucks off your
first box and free shipping in the lower
48 just go to butcher box comm slash
Church and use promo code Church and
checkout listen I'm gonna be checking up
on your mother [ __ ] okay if you get
butcher box you're gonna get an extra
little reward from me but you also gotta
cook the wings a certain way not
teriyaki like [ __ ] boy not none of that
[ __ ] it's Frank's hot sauce and a stick
of butter and you whip it around and you
put them in there and then you take it
out and you [ __ ] sift them if you're
not gonna do that I cut up nice blue
cheese with a nice piece of celery don't
deal with me no more don't even listen
to this [ __ ] podcast go to poyo logo
and I hope you choke to death anyway the
church is also brought to you by zip
recruiter it's a new year the perfect
opportunity to take your business to the
next level by hiring the right people
but finding qualified candidates can be
challenging see if I snooze if true that
wouldn't have leaked zip recruiter comms
last Church makes it easy zipper cooler
sends your job to over a hundred of the
web's leading job boards listen let's
cut out this [ __ ] zipper cool is so
effective that for the five employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate but through through the site
within the first day can you imagine
that all the time they're gonna save him
right now the church family gets zip
recruiter for free gratis
niente zipper cooler doc tom slash
church that's how easy this zipper
cooler dot-com / Church let me spell out
Church for you because you might be a
little stupid today I'm on a little out
of it CH you are CH zip recruited
dot-com slash Church the smartest way to
hire song of the day is you and I play
it take that [ __ ] meal Lee anyway
there ain't no muted kick I had to send
them back because everybody's getting in
trouble these days
you can't even I can't wait till they
come back to me and say hey Joey you're
in trouble because you told me to kick
that [ __ ] meal but anyway I don't
give a [ __ ] about meals except to my
older sister Sarah
my main man is here today representing
Buffalo on some great little comedian
Josh Potter thanks so much for having me
- I've known you since before the
glasses you've made me very proud
whereas got much number one yeah I know
you've been here for about a year
mm-hm a little over almost two years
it's so crazy how you see you go to
different comedy clubs and you see
comics and a hundred of them tell you
what their plans are and you talk to
them and you try to poke them as
honestly as you can I've always spoken
to you uh-huh and then you see him out
here
and you try to give them love or
whatever in the beginning is what I've
learned and I've learned that they go
home within the six first six months for
sure
this is a hard place to make a living
thank God you were friends of Tom and he
loves you with all his heart yeah I'm so
thankful I've had a thousand
conversations at Tom and you know you
gave me a little gig on the podcast
Tupelo changing your pocket you're doing
some work around town so I really
applaud thank you what you're doing I'm
very very very very proud that means so
much thank you very much no I'm you know
me dog I'm down with uh don't don't call
me at 2:00 in the morning and tell me
about your plants because I don't want
to [ __ ] you right and I don't like
talking about that I want to see what
the [ __ ] you're doing I hear around town
Josh Potter was there and you're very
likable I'm not everybody talks says
they love you I know you want to podcast
a couple weeks ago and somebody actually
called me and said listen to this
podcast for father he's [ __ ] apeshit
and I go let me pay some part of it you
know you remind me of part of why I've
always fall in love we and I've never
told you know is that the guy that
called me that basically threatened my
life
listen to this he's built like you Wow
he looked like you in glasses like
you he had the intelligence of you know
maim it uh he ran the prison library now
he was from Buffalo Wow
and he had murdered his wife and the
mailman because he was [ __ ] the wife
ha he was on a tail end of a dirty if
you know whatever 20-year whatever and
he didn't say much he rolled his own
cigarettes he was just a bite he hung
out with another do from Buffalo we have
like four guys in the prison from
Buffalo Wow all the way out there yeah
they got together and watch the bills
and talk [ __ ] one guy was big t big
[ __ ] black dude his family on
the barbershop Buffalo you ever come the
Buffalo come to the corner yeah as a
thousand corners yeah yeah and and this
librarian I mean this librarian became
tight and there was we've ended acid all
night we got some acid gotten in there
cuz they couldn't test you for acid okay
and he was slow hallucinogenic died so
me him and a [ __ ]
maybe tore a Powell's like there would
be we were bad with his army barracks
and there would be a guard that would
drive around once an hour and you know
some nights you can't sleep you're
allowed to go outside and sit on the
barracks and read a book this night all
three it was will [ __ ] fly phrase I
can't and I mean this is acid acid in
difference like real like you're
tripping in your room yeah you know
you're [ __ ] the lights are on you did
the cops are coming yeah they're they
live the cops are are there and finally
I get a knock on my door and it's the
grip phase like man I can't take it in
my room though I got alright let's go
get the librarian we get more libraries
like thank God you came I was just
trying to see like devils and [ __ ]
laughter I remember sitting outside on a
bench this yo you you think about prison
here you see these movies and you think
about but no matter where you go on this
life whether it's a negative or a
positive
you always meet two or three people that
are tight that make that part of your
life a lot easier and these two guys I
all my life and I'm sitting there with
them I'm more [ __ ] outside and the
birds are sounding like hawks you know
in the morning a little [ __ ] and the
strengthes went on and we were [ __ ]
really Paraguay class and the guard came
he's like what the [ __ ] are you guys
still doing nothing like we couldn't
talk we're talking about a shipment of
me coming in or some [ __ ] cuz we all
worked in the kitchen mmm so except the
librarian so what happened and at one
point the librarian goes I gotta go to
the bathroom he disappeared for like a
half I just lost them and tore a pals to
Crypt looked amigos how [ __ ] crazy we
would do an acid with a guy that stabbed
his wife did that's the mailman because
I'll never forget this [ __ ] wild
because you're right like a murderer on
acid could he have listened the homie
yeah and he was like he was a sweetheart
there was no mental health issues he was
a genius he was very smiling I learned
vane him you know I remember I was like
the house lawyer mm-hmm and he did all
my work oh he did all the paper because
of changes no he'd just get out of doing
it oh that's quite just to help me cuz
he was that smart he was initiative he
was just here and he read that New York
Times front to back everyday you know
it's just uh Buffalo has always been
just so [ __ ] I have such a connection
to Buffalo that I take my collection to
Jersey I met a girl from Buffalo and I
started going to Buffalo and I fell in
love with the city and they told me the
history of the city you know Fisher
Price left and all these companies left
and they were left with the dickham and
you were probably there in the 90s when
it was like real shitty everyone's
moving a [ __ ] Charlotte and I was
there in 84
okay so you saw the downturn like the
whole way I was
in 84 85 86 we would go was a family and
they were tremendous they were polish
yeah and the [ __ ] food was just
sensational my met and I remember
telling somebody once like I'm going to
Buffalo do comedy like that's the
[ __ ] of the world but I actually
really really got insulted like you
don't know Buffalo yeah
like unless you've been to Buffalo you
know when you go to [ __ ] Wegmans
uh-huh as you least likely wouldn't come
back from Rochester and she told me
about Wegmans like you just would not
the old I go back to Buffalo a Rob
Lederman yep when he paid nothing and it
was a nightmare of a club yeah and then
I went back when there was a funny bone
there the in the mall and that was
sensational that was cool that was the
first club in the country that was doing
blue shows oh no [ __ ]
Friday nights and Canadians would come
over yeah they loved coming after it was
sold out no matter who it was true blue
on Friday nights and 11:00 laughs it was
like seven nine and 11 I was like a
little kid back and they the owners it
was a great club because it was across
the street from the Wegmans yeah yeah
and the condo was 50 feet away right so
you cross the street and they'd have
these [ __ ] fresh wings and I'm not
talking about these California HIV wings
you bite into them and they've been
glued together yeah it's brown me I'm
talking about you you bite into a
drumstick way like you're eating
steroids and you don't give a flying way
to get buff alone try one why can't they
have wings everywhere I don't underst
it's 20/20 why everywhere you know I
made a statement on Rogaine years ago on
people some people took it the right way
and some food took it the wrong way um
listen there's a thousand I was watching
dives drives and all
bills and there's a place over here in
Glendale I went there a few times for
Cuban food I don't know guys
I got viagra three weeks ago I still
haven't taken it I'm a traditional type
of dude yeah yeah I blew em you know I
haven't been whacked off in three
[ __ ] weeks
Wow well I'm bright because I can't get
a hard-on this ever since I am I am
stirring I mean the dick gets kind of
hard looks like a cocaine ya know yeah
so I'm till these squats are back up to
300 that's when I get that blood back
into that right I'll be ready to squirt
some [ __ ] Oh
yum-yum juice on mom but you don't want
to try it you want to [ __ ] with the
viagra no I'm too petrified yeah I'm
petrified he worried about happening a
heart attack or something I see yeah you
know but they said viagra was invented
for your heart no but uh as long as
you're not mixing it with coke and [ __ ]
no that's usually that's not like wildin
died and all yeah I'm not doing that
yeah that's what scares me so your
traditional guy with the wings I'm a
traditional dude how much additional
dude with anything I give everybody
their respect I'm not gonna put ranch
I'm [ __ ] hungry now Huggies I'm not
gonna put ranch on Petes I don't put
pineapple on pizza pizza was not made to
have mine an apple on it there's a Sun
that we've created
you know Taco Bell invents [ __ ] by the
day
chalupa even maxi mcsweats their heads
go what the [ __ ] you look what so the
more you feed into this the more they're
gonna keep creating and I listen I
appreciate different things
I really do I appreciate you trying and
your efforts but guess what I don't want
your fusion [ __ ] Chinese I want the
original stuff you know when I go to my
lot of Buffalo I go to the hotel room
dog I swear to God
whatever hotel I gonna I go little bro I
put my [ __ ] down I roll the [ __ ]
joint while it's dry and I go on uber
and I see what it's gonna cost me what
it does
and it really doesn't matter yeah
they're another one I don't care if they
open downtown to six hours I call the
feature and I go be downstairs in five
minutes I bar and I go right there ducks
and you know it used to be the anchor
but I think I went to the anchor ball
once it wasn't for me its officers way
manner he talks his way better anchor
was where it was started and where they
use blue cheese you know buffle doesn't
have you know buffalo has been getting
[ __ ] in the ass mmm-hmm for two
thousand years mainly the the major
league baseball really Buffalo Bisons
have been the number one attendance I
don't know if it's still alive today I
mean we still crush it on occasion but
they've turned teams over so many times
since the 90s that it's like the product
on the field was shitty for like ten
years like when we were the Mets
affiliate and [ __ ] but back when we were
the Pirates and the Indians and [ __ ] we
were crushing it cuz they were the
attendance is no more for minor league
baseball since the fifties Wow and they
went out there I don't know what year
was maybe 90 something they were
thinking of expanding mm-hmm but they
went out there in April first and they
were walking on a [ __ ] yeah four feet
of snow and I feel yeah and then we
can't have baseball
well it's 2020 and I know you've made
innovations with domes yeah I know
you've made innovation not only don't if
climate change is real that shit's gonna
be dried up by the time climate change
israel no I know that Buffalo you used
to get four feet of snow it's definitely
a final regular I could see them getting
ten feet 12 feet one is that were you
there when they got 11 feet one year
yeah that was in 2015 and it was like in
a narrow area of the city because it was
just like this they called it a knife
storm it came over the lake and it was
like this couple mile wide area of the
city just narrow that had 11 feet of
snow in it football season but then also
in playing like Tennessee or something
yeah we had to move the game
- like an away game but like the the
craziest part though is that in January
so many times in recent years there's
like a 70 degree day all of a sudden so
that's where I see like I'm like this
isn't something that I remember as a
little kid you know like having
stretches of days in those 60s and 70s
and January that's [ __ ] up and then in
March you know shits off-the-wall in
April like you said there's still snow
sometimes there's snow as late as May
yeah it's crazy
it's all over the map you born and
raised in Buffalo yeah I live there
until I moved here basically 31 is way
too bad it's wrong my dad is born in
Egypt and his mother and him moved to
Buffalo when he was 17 but he's Greek he
was a Greek guy living area [ __ ] the
Egyptian yeah yeah did I bring the other
join up with me tell me I left on the
car left on the car what type of [ __ ]
I'm hosting my anyway I'm gonna move to
smoke my mother joined again I think I
can go get it
you know I mean I'm a fast man as all
I'm saying I can run yeah yeah it's in a
bag in the front seat on the passenger
side passenger side right in the front
seat is a bank there's three other hates
in there okay just bring the whole bag
okay let's get down it's a white Subaru
oh thank you sir you're a gentleman the
[ __ ] scarf no I've been going to
Buffalo for a long [ __ ] time a lot of
people that know that that they were so
now they should have a buffalo but you
don't well we have Toronto buddies and
they have a dope yeah they should have
like a big now with the technologies and
everything that they have Buffalo was
ready for a [ __ ] baseball team the
only reason why they I don't know what
the [ __ ] going on that was 12 years
ago what they're don't quote me on this
just go to Wikipedia and look it up and
see when the last time Major League
Baseball when I was a kid Buffalo had
the bills and they also had the Buffalo
Braves and the Sabres they sell the
Sabres and then then the Buffalo Braves
is a basketball team I don't know about
that yeah Randy Johnson
they had a great [ __ ] team for a
while as a kid not like
Bishop level team but it the basketball
team leaving fisher-price leaving all
these other corporations leaving really
really left when all those corporation
is left in the [ __ ] 70s when it was
fisher-price Buffalo Braves right the
basketball team with Randy Smith on it
and [ __ ] it was like it was like one bad
[ __ ] head after the other for Buffalo
so the economy really went down for
years there was a giant factory that
manufactured like cars and parts and
stuff closed down and like that was like
thirty percent of the jobs for something
in the scissors a really Bethlehem Steel
shut down it was really sad I'm him
being in Buffalo doing and you always
see it I always say hello to rod when I
go up yeah Rob yeah nice to work on the
other radius that I would pay you why no
yeah of course Rob featured you guys Rob
had a reputation of being like a bad guy
or whatever like I mammoths getting the
call and gone when you go up there be
careful with him he's kind of weird and
stuff and I was always very respectful
even as a feature act until you
disrespected me and then either I was
just gonna tell you to go [ __ ] yourself
we were gonna box it out or whatever the
[ __ ] was gonna happen you know uh-huh
and Rob's week started on a Wednesday
and that Tuesday night I was probably to
go to comedy festival and that's the
night when that prick put me up after
the salsa band called Jesus but
something did good happen that I got an
audition for The Sopranos from doing
that thing so I had to meet her the next
day at 11 o'clock my bus to Buffalo was
a 12o from Port Authority so I met her
got in a cab shot to Port Authority took
the eight-hour bus to Buffalo god help
us Ryan did the Wednesday night
and they called Wednesday night and said
we need you back of New York there's bad
so I basically had to hop on a red-eye
bus [ __ ] sleep at Port Authority
washed my face and at 10:00 go to a
producer session of The Sopranos and
then cats that same bus I caught the day
before at 12:00 go back get back there
7:30 jump in the shower go right into
the show oh my god and Rob help me get
the sides Rob help me audition oh that's
what I can't forget that was a he paid
me $450 for a week I'll never forget
that yeah he I mean him and I had like a
tough introduction because we worked on
not cut we worked in the same building
but they were competing shows you know
and I was the comedian on this show and
he was the comedian on that show and he
obviously was a comic for 20 years
yeah he's been a comic million-year got
a real resident of course ya know about
Rob Lee the man is that he's not like a
fake club owner right Rob Lee the man
came out here gave this shot and figure
the better way off right right and I'm
never mad at somebody
not at all if Lee comes to me tomorrow
and he goes hey man I got talked about
some some guy at Wooster he's opening up
a radio station and he offered me a good
job not big money but my mother's
getting older and I'm open to making it
yeah I could go to Boulder do the radio
show cuz Rob Lee invented that whole
move yeah I mean he was making big money
and he lead and that gold anyway well is
that success right yeah well mine was
the other way around kind of like Rob
came out here he was doing the road he
was like a headliner and he was a part
of the big boom at that time the
eighties boom and then he got an offer
to be on this morning show that was a
heritage morning show and it was at the
time probably huge money I mean it
probably was like insane
and so he took that and he also like ran
a business and then he opened a club
comics CAF what was it called comics
cafe yeah yeah and I started running the
club out there and was still doing local
sets and he ran the whole fire hall
circuit that's why my introduction to
rob was like tenuous at first because I
was trying to get into the game you know
what I mean I was trying to get sets I
was trying to get shows and Rob's like
you know you're new or whatever so I got
it at some point like it took a couple
years but I got where he was coming from
and we made amends and I just did his
show the other day like Collin on it but
yeah so I mean he's we're totally cool
you know nowadays but there was a couple
years there where I didn't think we're
cool yeah I never forgot that solid he
did to me now when I met you you worked
where the first time now see that's the
thing when I met you I moved to do radio
and Cleveland for us eight-mile gotcha -
Cleve not were you already doing
stand-up you were just doing radius well
I was doing both okay well you start
stand-up I started stand-up in 2008
we're in Buffalo okay so I started radio
and nothing was there that no it was a
bar that nici's bar that was our whole
world - Tuesday nights there that was
everything and you had come to do a show
later on in life at that bar with Ari no
no that was at the town ballroom that's
where I met you yeah but then remember
when you came back he came alone and did
that bar for the further lesbian comic
yeah yeah so but yeah when I met you I
had just moved to Cleveland to start
that radio show and I was gone maybe
like three weeks when we did that gig at
the town ballroom it was called it was a
theater a rock club me you and our yeah
and then I went to do that radio show in
Cleveland and there was a Rob Lederman
that I worked for there so to speak a
comic named Chuck booms do you know who
that name is he used to work with Bud
Freeman he was he used to close out a
knee at The Improv so he had credits he
was around but working with it this guy
was a nightmare like this guy was such a
piece of [ __ ] and I just I was like I
can't work with this guy and my old show
actually
heard me a job to come back with like
more money and stuff so I was like [ __ ]
it I'm gonna go back and I thought that
was it from him like I'm just gonna die
on this radio station or whatever I was
gonna work here forever and I did that
for about five more years before I came
out here so however many were you
wouldn't Buffalo yeah you got the luck
that helium open that's that saved my
life and that saved your life
exact was Buffalo needed a comedy room
and the desperate wave and buffalo
supports calm it does like they [ __ ]
support calmly so how big is Buffalo is
it like a medium-sized city small in
terms of media markets its number like
fifty three or something like that so
it's a mid-sized market in terms of
media I don't know how what that
translates to in other ways but you know
it's it's decent size I I love Buffalo
so much and I wish I could do more there
I kind of like hit the ceiling you know
I was like I'm gonna fight with the
radio guy yes that's that's that's the
show Rob worked on right wasn't that the
same wonder was that oh I got into a
fight it was Portland a buffalo helium
okay I went in and I said something
about if you kick through the guys like
what my kids been getting bullied and I
don't know what to do it well your kid
gets bullied you give him some boxing
gloves and you teach them out of box and
at the break the guys took this your
phone's off how dare you say that to me
I go that's the truth Oh unless you want
to raise the [ __ ] on behalf of
fruitcakes when we went on the air he
kept the conversation go like how you
would raise a child I would hate to be
your child and I'm like i'm like punk
your child one that's getting bullied
say one more word now climb a crawl we
were added that's why I don't think I
was invited then we went back and forth
on Facebook for like about myself you
[ __ ] Punk and then people started to
hate them oh mighty [ __ ] [ __ ] it
was tremendous to all the club later and
then when I went back the club's like
yeah he doesn't ever want a comedian
again oh that's wild
that wasn't Buffalo I don't think I
would have
finally heard about that but I I can't
believe you remember that first gig we
did with Ari that was like I knew you
might you remember me obviously from the
weekends we did but I didn't know you
remember that far back because that was
like I remember you had that banana
bread and [ __ ] oh and I ate like so
[ __ ] much of it that I just had a
great time it was like the best comedy
experience of my life to that point at
that point you know what I'm saying like
cuz I was 3 years in or something like
that I couldn't believe I got that
hosting gig and I had just moved to
Cleveland and I hated it and I was like
I gotta get back to what am i doing why
did I leave you know I know it's crazy
that I owe Buffalo something you know
when you become a comic and you're young
you there's a couple cities after you
start rock that you just want to hit for
the tradition of the city like I want to
go to Houston on a respect for Bill
Hicks I wanted to go to Boston out of
respect for all the great comments that
have been in Boston I wanna go to you
know there was just little places that I
needed to go not Chapel Hill North
Carolina because there are my favorite
basketball team Buffalo I went to just
with a girl and I kept going and then
later on the years later I became a
comic and then Rob Lederman threw me a
[ __ ] curveball I was uh you know I'm
gonna light anybody I'm a regular at the
calm you storm been there about two
years I'm bombing 75% but not as bad as
I was I had a pile under my belt for CBS
and I think I had just done Matt no no
MADtv with a handle but I had nothing I
did a Taco Bell commercial I go to
Buffalo because I went to Buffalo a
couple times so I go to Rob Lederman the
first time and then the second time I go
back for Rob Lee them and again but that
time we have a problem yeah
I'm talking about a big big big problem
not drugs
nope it's not alcohol it's a problem I
know you're gonna say it's a comic it's
a problem that it's a comics nightmare
and a comic doesn't know till he gets
there and it's called when your local
sports team when your local sports team
is in the playoffs there's three types
of bars there's you know Buffalo Wild
Wings with a bunch of jerk-offs jumping
up and down nobody buy the dollar on the
game mm-hmm then there's that medium one
where they have a little bit more money
and they all have jerseys on one side is
sitting on the other side and it's very
[ __ ] if you got a machine gun and
shot them all nobody would miss them as
I'm saying yeah yeah and then this is a
bleep people that are missing teeth that
this is their life mm-hmm that's the
whole city of Buffalo and read the
reports of who got drafted yeah they
dude this is their life you know Denver
I love you to death Jesus I love Jesus
but if you make a comeback don't make it
there in a Bronco game gonna be there I
mean yeah you're describing me things
exactly I mean I'm I'm the same way
yeah I can't why do I do it Thursday
Wednesday night I have a pretty decent
set and this is where a lot of things
progress for me this is where everything
started for me if I look back I have to
think about Buffalo I get there Thursday
and Rob goes we have a problem
it's Game five you know they're getting
angry and angry what year was this may I
ask you know Goga I do not know it must
have been like 2001 2002 maybe around
around there because I was having
problems here like as a comic anytime
earlier before let's see what year the
buff
we'll say well I mean I can help you out
with all that I mean there was a there
was a there was a string of years though
between 98 and oh four we went every
year to the playoffs okay so and we went
to the Stanley Cup in 99 and okay I
don't know what the actual cup okay yeah
I don't know dick about dick I'm trying
to snort coke and get my dick sucked and
trying to get my meat to resume you know
whatever I mean you're out there on the
road you're a young kid you know women
are talking to you have to shows
whatever I want people understand that
these are all [ __ ] jokes and we'll
get the the situation later but I'm out
there I'm just learning the ropes I'm a
feature act I'm opening for anybody and
they do you remember who it was that
weekend the dirtiest guy in Buffalo with
glasses all the guy the dirtiest job
Bobby what is this on Bobby not the
hypnotist do know John Bowlby was the
song the singer this guy don't play the
piano he this guy's a little off-color
okay Yoda used them a lot off-color dues
couldn't work a lot of club solid
understood where I was coming from and I
knew where he was coming from so I get
then he goes this is gonna be the deal
we're gonna put the emcee up and then
it's gonna be halftime and we're gonna
put you up and then you go eat and then
they're gonna do another two quarters
and then fuckos gonna go up so they show
the show they show the game out there so
you're doing a shift between periods so
this calmly show who's gonna get be put
on while the save the game because
there's no way that people would
tolerate the judge not gonna turn to
save a game walk dude I I just said that
I was in Boston at laughs Boston my
first headlining weekend of my life at
laughs Boston and they put the [ __ ] in
Patriots wild-card game the same night
as as like you know eight feet it's at
8:15 on Saturday night I'm like oh great
no the shows are gonna get cancelled
though
I still I still sold like almost a
hundred and fifty tickets that night and
it was like what I I was like even more
mad at [ __ ] Patriot fan because I was
like if that show if that even they
won't even have those shows in Buffalo
if they said 8:15 Saturday night show in
Buffalo on a [ __ ] wild card playoff
game that shows canceled
there's no shot that they would [ __ ]
put a game on when Brad I I did a New
Year's Eve with Brad Williams
the night that we broke the playoff
drought and the game went long in 7:30
show and the game went long and then we
won the game and that wasn't enough we
had to watch the Bengals Ravens game the
end of that on the giant screen because
if the Bengals won we make the playoffs
so they waited even more of an extra
half hour for that because all people
were gonna never leave the bar if they
didn't put it on in the showroom so
people would sit down like [ __ ] cuz
they're [ __ ] animals they need to
like be herded into the showroom did we
split at least they'll be in their seats
so in the game's over we can start the
show I don't I don't hate the bills it's
not like the Yankees for me but I don't
like the bills right but I respect teams
like that I respected there's no reason
for you to hate us because you've been
destroying us for be Johnny fan Boyle
video is that I went up during halftime
I think they were down oh okay they were
down and so people are a shitty mood and
I'll no forget that I hope they're
thinking I was gonna be the Captain Kirk
daily enterprise and it was the longest
25 minutes of my life I mean guys it was
it was just think of getting punched in
the face
25 can't even imagine that it was the
Dallas Stars series - Game five I'm
thinking I'm gonna walk off and get
fired he's gonna call Yoda this is the
end of my Yoda career that's big - you
know
you know in your a feature act and
you're making four or five hours a week
Yoder keeps your pork chops and I walked
off and a couple people Clapton how
about people said thank God
and I remember wanting to kill myself
but we didn't came up to me and said
good job man you didn't get anything
thrown at you they didn't leave great
job are you [ __ ] not I feel like that
right now is a could have been worse she
could have been getting stitched up
right now yeah they didn't laugh because
they couldn't laugh in those moment they
were polite about it they enjoyed you
right away then 'ok now let's go back to
ten years later and me watching bill
bird philadelphia okay i follow me and
i'm like oh god like I was getting a
couple boos and did they want to cheat
me on behind you on mute oh oh yeah I
would worry about that very polite my
mother gave me don't [ __ ] immune
anything oh no yeah thankfully when I
started comedy the Sabres had just like
I remember the first couple years I'd be
so pissed at the Sabres because you know
you have your sets during the week and
you're like no one's gonna [ __ ] come
there's a [ __ ] game tonight and then
finally like the Sabres had ten years of
sucking and they just became an odd
people are like well gonna do something
else I'm not gonna watch those Sabres
the Sabres like suck so long recently
that it's weighing down a little bit
they still sell out games but I mean
like people aren't watching them
feverishly every [ __ ] night you know
like I could see myself if it wasn't for
the winter's moving my family to Buffalo
it's a great place for a family it
really is well I like the state of mind
them Buffalo I met a lot of good people
from Buffalo who I mean when I went to
Boulder
the people around it were Buffalo people
yeah man and the guy would have Monday
Night Football parties
whenever Buffalo was going on and you go
over there adult this is how you doin no
his mother would overnight which could
be found wet no not the beach she mama
cooked the beef himself that canola
crawls she would overnight the Kimmel
worker Oh mommy's these guys were hit
yeah
and while they were watching the game
they would put the helmet on and I still
remember one Monday night where the kid
kept jumping a lot and he told them
don't jump and the kid jumped and
cracked his head open they had an ice
bag on the kid's head kids bleeding and
the father's like we're not going next
time don't jump you're not going to the
hospital till after the Bills game yeah
kids how the mom was crying bleeding
[ __ ] them I get I'm like yeah yeah this
is something the kid was dummy she way
to the fourth quarter bang bang is but
all these experience take me back to
Buffalo so I can't imagine like what
when did you at the rate was there point
at the radio station just because
there's people in like to this duck man
dude I worked there for 15 years almost
I started working when I was 16 so I
didn't know anything else you know and I
except for that time that I went to
Cleveland you know and I didn't know
that I was like this is gonna be my life
but then the jobs just started
disappearing there's no there was no
upward place to go it just it went away
at first it looked like the you know
when you first started 16 you know it
was 2004 or some [ __ ] and I was like the
sky's the limit I could be Howard Stern
someday but then you know you started
seeing like the nuts and bolts of this
thing and it's going away or whatever
and like the jobs are getting paid less
etc so I just was like you know and I
never thought I thought comedy would be
like my second thing for a while do you
know what I mean like when I was until I
was 22 then I was like no this has to
flip around and radio is the secondary
thing because it's not taking me
anywhere comedy is taking me places
already you know
so out of the gate I'm doing things that
I've never dreamed of doing so it
flipped out like 22 and I started taking
I did stand-up every you know that's
when I started really doing it you know
because the last time I saw you really
working the helium rotation yeah I mean
you're really in the rotation and you
own a Philly I think I never went to
Philly they only had me going between
st. Louis and Buffalo honesty number
seven you worked at me and st. Louis yep
and that third weekend it opened
that was you know listen you've all
heard me fart look at different
platforms I'm not gonna sit here with a
farm like a soldier I'm too old and
whatever comes out so be it and if you
sittin close to me that's life I've been
held a couple great farts myself I held
some bad ones what we talking about fart
fire Louis st. Louis yeah st. Louis I
got on stage that Thursday night and I'm
on stage Lee and I'm just smelling fart
after fart after fart I don't care as I
do the same thing once you're on a fart
roll why stop but it was in that area
so and I kept looking at each of them
trying to figure out who was dropping
these bonds like they were bomb like you
could tell her they're coming for you
I'm like Jesus so boom [ __ ] it's Friday
then I go up there for the first show
and I'm smelling [ __ ] bombs again
what the [ __ ] is this and it's like
every 15 minutes just a new one yeah
it's like refreshing Friday night I
smelled it I couldn't figure out it was
in my nose I went there sadly and sad
that I started walking people people
will walk in Saturday early from the
smell
yes I thought it was Mia yeah yeah and
your heart breaks on that's right yeah
you're number get up and next thing you
know [ __ ] afterwards I love Brown
what does [ __ ] and they're like every
time you flush the toilet ups
is they didn't know that when they
rented the place so it's like there was
like construction going on or something
too and so it was like all the plumbing
was all [ __ ] up there was like
something that kept backing up but it
was it's in a mall like a new addition
of a mall at the time so they're doing
all this new [ __ ] and everything and so
yeah every time someone flush the toilet
we'd get like a out a vent or some [ __ ]
you know like right into the showroom oh
you just invalid so fun I like it I mean
I'm keeping my head clean and I'm
working hard you know where you live I
live in East Hollywood you know I miss
Buffalo in a lot of ways but also
they're those same things I go like I
need to do something else too you know
what I mean I got exceed something else
and live somewhere else experience new
things and so I love it living here so
far the sun's nice you know it's uh I
don't drive anymore I sold my car when I
moved here and I just said I'm not
driving when I go to LA and it's been
been easier than I ever expected and
it's kind of a weight lifted off me I
don't know if you remember I had like
all these like [ __ ] driving mishaps
and like arrests and [ __ ] like that from
driving sighs um you know driving all
over the place
like up getting tickets here and there
and I was [ __ ] I was poor so I wouldn't
pay this one or I would like let it
lapse or whatever so driving was always
dicey for me give me like terrible
anxiety and so I'm happy that I don't
have to do that anymore plus I'm going
blind so I probably shouldn't drive
anyway yeah so far so good it's uh kick
staying in there you know it's I
probably should get new glasses soon but
other than that it's been it's fine you
know I'm blind in this eye but other
than this look at this one going it is
yeah but I've done things to slow it
down uh so I mean I'm sure when I'm like
middle-aged or whatever when people's
eyes start going again I'm probably
gonna have like some hiccups but
hopefully whatever is in place there is
good enough to withstand some of that
you know I mean they tell you all this
[ __ ] about [ __ ] reefer smoke remember
that was the first excuse yeah oh god
that's why I stopped
ton of it just to be sure I smoked
reefer all the time I can't wait for
that doctor to tell me I've got calm I'm
gonna smack him I've been preparing for
glaucoma since I was like eight I would
never [ __ ] have know the one that the
glaucoma is not the one that you I mean
everyone gets like a cataract at some
point I think you know I have one I
don't even bother taking out of it cuz
it's like I can't see how that [ __ ]
eye anyway so it gives a [ __ ] cataract
anyway
you know but yeah I mean that st. Louis
weekend I remember it was a Super Bowl
too and I remember being like all the
Super Bowls tomorrow me and the MC we're
gonna drive 12 hours after that show on
Saturday night so we dropped you off and
then we just drove to Buffalo after that
right yeah no where'd you drop me off
yeah Hotel because we went that night
like it was like The Late Show Saturday
and then we just drove home after The
Late Show and because I remember yeah I
was like oh I'm so they were alive right
you and the manager sung me in tile the
MC count and CC yeah he's gotten the car
after the show and I'm gonna be telling
you to stop I thought yeah yeah yeah
I drove a straight he fell asleep like
right away he's like I'll sleep now and
then I'll wake up and drive the second
half so we can get home by like one
o'clock taking a nap watch the Superbowl
and I ended up he ended up waking up at
like 9:00 a.m. and I'm like I'm good
dude I'll just finish it and I did I
just drove because I wanted to see that
[ __ ] so I wanted to see that Super
Bowl but wasn't there time we were
telling me when we first met that like
there was a time you like went back and
forth from Cleveland to Buffalo oh when
I lived there and when I did those shows
like with you I had all these shows
lined up before I move because it was
like a the whole thing of me getting
that job offer to me moving was seven
days I had to decide if I want to go and
I had to be there in seven days to like
launch the show so it was all very quick
and I had all these shows booked in
Buffalo including the one I did with you
and so I was just like had my apartment
and Buffalo still and then I got like I
was just sleeping in my Jeep in
Cleveland
and then like waking up and like taking
a shower at like the gym and then going
into work at 3:00 a.m. to do morning
radio and then driving back like on the
weekends to sleep in my apartment in
Buffalo and like do the shows basically
so yeah that was like I think I drove to
Cleve from Cleveland to Buffalo the
morning of that show and then slept in
my apartment that just had a mattress in
it and then woke up with my cousin and
drove back to to clean one and just butt
back telling work people really never
know and if you look back at those times
you like was I [ __ ] crazy yeah like
what would make you drive and sleep in
your [ __ ] car it's a love yeah it's a
passion what would make what would make
it okay like if you went to the normal
college educated person and told that to
what would they say to you it makes me
sad that some people don't have that at
all there's nothing they would do that
for you know there's a lot of people in
the world that have nothing that makes
them feel that way that makes me kind of
sad for them but they probably think I'm
crazy for saying that but it was really
weird because before the age of 28
nothing was worth living and dying for
and somehow another I got locked up and
you know get exposed to more comedy in a
scene dice and then I'm like I'm gonna
do stand-up you know what we talked
about a billion die off or something
yeah like sleeping in a large [ __ ] I was
not one for me I went from loving
cocaine like that was my only passion
like I liked sex I like girls are like
Szechuan beef I like pork egg rolls you
know there was nothing but everything
was like that I like music I love music
but I love cocaine calmly swept me off
my feet and it was like that for
you listen it's like anything else
you're making 320 a week let's say
you're making 350 a week then you're
clearing 1,400 a month you've got your
apartment yeah you call a payment you
got the food and you put away 200 a
month to feel lucky you're not living at
the Taj Mahal you living in a basement
from time to time you catch a rat you
know and [ __ ] like that
I come to you and I go listen a lady
come work for me the only problem is a
straight Commission this happens in life
that but I know my regularly guys I got
a guy that's a half for rethought and he
walks out here with two g's a week and
you imagine what you would do
I mean the first week you [ __ ]
skeptical as [ __ ] yeah you bet you're
fine you losing money by the hour but
then it's like by Wednesday you get like
300 you're like okay so I made what I
made last week Thursday Friday you take
a chance the first week you make 800
you're like okay then you make up the
housing in the second week then are you
actually making two grand consistently
you know are you gonna fall in love with
that job no yes you are well yeah I was
giving you 300 a week mm-hmm and all of
a sudden I gave you eight hundred a week
and all of a sudden now you're making
1,200 a week see you're making 4,800 a
month
oh you have a wife and a kid okay wife
isn't shocked because you've been an
idiot all your life you know what are
you doing while I'm selling plumbing
supplies on the phone so what do you do
now you go to the library if you're a
[ __ ] normal person and you find that
the in announced is selling because it
seems like sales is in your future
because you're making 350 at the [ __ ]
video store now you're doing this you're
getting better every mom
so now you read about sales to know the
psychology about sales sure and now
you're all in
now you just took your family from a
[ __ ] one tax bracket to the other and
you rose them again because you got into
what you were doing and you're gonna
have bad months there's gonna be a month
that you just don't nobody wants to buy
[ __ ] glasses yeah so you're [ __ ]
same thing is a comedy
Oh same thing is there anything else you
get into you're always skeptical at
first then you get a little bit of
success and now you go if I got a little
bit of success with that shitty effort
mm-hmm
can you imagine if I [ __ ] jumped at
that first interesting yeah and that's
when you see the results of everything
and that's when I got a gig for you in
Buffalo and you're like I'll take it but
you didn't call Trailways before you
[ __ ] left yeah and there's a
four-hour delay in Albany from 2:30 in
the morning to 6:30 in the morning
good luck yeah and they closed the bus
station and there's nothing to eat for
three miles and when there is a [ __ ]
Popeyes Chicken
but there ain't no [ __ ] savory
characters hanging out and on top of
that all you have is six dollars any way
to get you to Buffalo hell yeah
you're gonna get to the [ __ ] condo
hopefully they'll be [ __ ] the comic
before left cereal in there and then
then when you go in then that you'll get
a draw after your first show to make the
file all week yep that takes love yeah
that takes long time smiling when you're
describing that vs all tails thing the
sales thing I'm like oh no no of course
I'm comparing it to apples and peaches
of your horse all the same [ __ ] yeah
like the thing for me and I
I love doing stand-up when I keep
talking I discovered sure I'm nowhere
near you guys but I can't I can't
imagine look like sleeping in my car one
night a month with one night a week
because I'm on the road and in between
like San Francisco in LA I could do that
but there's people who I couldn't
imagine living in my corner regular
basis well it wasn't for me I was lucky
I mean I I wasn't a regular basis I was
like probably a couple weeks here and
there okay because I just didn't have an
apartment there and I couldn't afford to
have a hotel every night so I would just
you know I worked in an office and I got
a gym membership and I just would shower
at the gym and then I had a cool car a
big enough car that it didn't even
matter and then also my father at the
time I was working for a business like
he worked in a in a for a restaurant
inside of a hotel chain okay kind of
thing I won't say which one but then
like he would give me like a discount on
the room so I'd have one like here and
there okay yeah it was a like for like
three weeks it was like three weeks I
guess like that I cuz I also couldn't
just afford to buy another apartment out
of nowhere yet you know and I mean I had
wonderful flow but yeah so it was like
it wasn't like I was living in my car
for like a six months time or something
like that or like a year okay I'm still
tough but it was that stretch yeah and
then I mean when I lived in in Cleveland
I I when I found an apartment I just
like slept I I just was like I never
really moved into it I just kind of
slept on the ground and right I've had
my first couple experiences with condos
in the last few months and there's
nothing uh fancy but I like if I could
do it and somehow I would like to live
but like I could do but the I understand
I like maybe because I came up in comedy
in this past decade the condo situations
have never been unsafe there's never
been a condo that I've been in where
I've been like this is worse than my
apartment because I've just lived I
guess in squalor myself so I've always
got who to the condo going like let's go
on complaining about if not like this is
kind of nice
yeah so I mean like that's the thing
that like I'm starting to learn living
in LA is like I'm starting to grow up a
little bit more in terms of just like my
own lifestyle choices you know what I
mean like you're describing the unsavory
characters at the Popeyes I was just
that guy like I was the unsavory
character at the Popeyes 99 um it's a
Monday morning I just got paid by Riley
and yeah like some staff member
saved me 30 bucks 20 by giving me a ride
to the bus station down less I'm [ __ ]
his static I don't know somewhere
wherever he dropped me off there was a
McDowell you know in those days I travel
while I have like my bag and then I went
and I got a [ __ ] egg sandwich with
the potato and the [ __ ] juice that's
an authority just to give you a little
orange juice
yeah and I'll never forget like whatever
that combo cost I gave her the 20 she
gives me the bag I [ __ ] you know I'm
welcome back to the bus station to be
honest it's a nice day in Buffalo the
sun's out and I'm like if I gotta sit in
a bus for seven and a half hours a month
we'll grab some Sun and I just finished
the egg sandwich I'm put the egg
container in the bag the potato holder
in the bag know about the foal that I'm
sipping the coke cause I was yeah I was
a fat [ __ ] sorry she's telling coke and
two apple pies for a dollar what the
[ __ ] bro give yourself a treat that's a
I see this black kid running towards me
he goes yo brother take a look you have
a gold chain in his hand and you could
see the the bracelets were broken like
where they were connected oh oh he's
looking back like he's like man either
by
mike is it Golden Eagles man there's a
[ __ ] pick cotton like I said something
like that to me like something [ __ ]
off-color all right give me 50 bucks
since it was a thick gold chain and I
was like Dawg but I took up the 16 and
change I had from the Mickey D's the
fort whatever yeah yeah I know this is
what I got I mean I gave the exact
whatever that lady gave me with the
receipt yes yeah yeah he goes done he
ran off getting the [ __ ] thing I get
the car I get in the bus I take it to
Manhattan yes already and I'm the whole
thing I'm looking at this and I'm like I
got beat I got beat this is a beat move
cuz it's not real it's not I thought in
my head first place I get off the bus I
go to a [ __ ] pawnshop guy ways that
he's like I get through 680 oh holy [ __ ]
he goes well it's a nice chain man why
are you getting rid of it I don't know
he goes for 20 bucks I'll put brackets
on it for you like oh go ahead and I
kept the chain for a while I'm selling
it somewhere that's wild yeah I think I
just want to crack real bad he just
ripped the [ __ ] chain on somebody's
neck oh my god damn Oh in Buffalo yeah
right that's a while by that bus station
downtown they don't play no let me taste
a little bit I used to take those buses
I knew all that you know I was involved
in a little romance in Syracuse oh you
went up and down that bus the that are
generic used well well you're 90 that
wasn't all but he had the family room at
the bus station that's not comedy work
sure this is 97 room at the buses that's
crazy
Oh hotel you just came in did this show
on the left did they put you up no with
an
your comic room booked by a guy named
Roger Pau okay and you would it was the
New York guys yeah because that's when
we took the train to haul but he got off
it was the audience of how missing teeth
you know hairos in their head a [ __ ]
hang tough on their wrists great people
here that New York to Buffalo bus ride
is uh I've done that a bunch make a
whole circuit yeah because if you take
Syracuse buff buff Syracuse buff Albany
buff Rochester there's always something
that's why I met the girl that
straight-up told me to my face this is
why I loved listen going on the road
makes you a great comic but your
matthäus I'm it's 30% of reason why
order up you go on the road yes to do
drugs and to do whatever and Lee doesn't
do drugs so he would go on the road to
eat a Chinese buffets or whatever he
does no use talking about barbecue what
we'll be talking it's only a third of
you know they say about the road is the
people you meet and the relationships
you make and you learn about the
university learn about you being hungry
you know you put yourself in all these
positions as a comic to get you so far
this hole which you should be doing as a
human being which is going on the
comfort zone you know and you just get
to meet the weird people especially on a
[ __ ] bus you know when you're I like
it I know for a fact without
exaggeration there was 20 times when I
was on a I had to wait for the next bus
and there was a three-hour gap and you
got four dollars in your pocket but you
got a joint you got a Walkman Universtiy
nagi air is no fun OCP
you don't like it but you shoplift today
that's it I'm I'm a midnight still like
singing yeah I'm a genie bottle you know
I remember being in that song slaps yeah
I've ever been in Saginaw Michigan and
staying in a hotel for 20 hours a night
and hearing people getting prostituted
and walking across the street because
the way it wouldn't be it was like a
Friday Saturday and a Fridays having in
the same area oh I don't know where it
goes yeah you go downtown when you ramp
by the room and you go to the bathroom
and there's a condom on the floor
because you have to chair you have to
share the the bathroom oh yeah like a
boarding house yeah you know I didn't
know there's no story you try right yeah
but the best angle was when I got on the
bus with this girl I'm like oh my god
she sat right next to me like I had the
window seat
and she split next to me and it was just
me and her I'm like oh my god this
girl's a [ __ ] 12 and I just was like
I'm not gonna say a word and she said
kind so what's your name
oh my god welcome to me and popping up
about what do you do what are you gonna
be doing and I think I was going to
Rochester maybe you're gonna know when I
tell you yeah and I said what are you
doing she goes well this have been
Barisan she was I'm an exotic dancer
okay so you going to wherever to dance
and she goes well I have to be honest
with you where I dance they do a health
inspection and I've got a disease
I've got like VD so the prescription
won't kick in and I'll have it for the
next week but if I go to this town they
don't check for a license all that is
extruding lousy yeah they had like some
type of stripping loss she had something
that she couldn't dance because it was
contagious
ha but she's like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
I don't know what I wish I knew the laws
the penalties and probably what I it was
it was between Buffalo Rochester awesome
comedy cafes right or two comic cafes
the one in Buffalo and then there was
that one in Rochester that jyoti guy
there was a the only club I remember in
Rochester was a club that was built on
cocaine yeah for the minute I walked in
there the owner had you're an addict I
think that's and it was it was just I
enjoyed doing it yeah I was a junkie so
I enjoyed being there but to be honest
you know I didn't enjoy being there
right right it was all over the place it
was like going to the club in Kansas
City it was like even Miami wasn't that
bad Wow because his staff was pretty
like you know this clubs you go to the
whole staffs on drugs
yeah most of the cities are hosted ass
on drugs the madman running around this
is their life this is their part of
their addictions part of the thing that
attracted me to blossom grace well not
be man that you're out here no man thank
you making moves I'm trying like you say
put the pieces together pieces together
some I wanted to talk to you about you
guys been ready you were radio for a
long time I've been doing this wrong
I'll listen what one when I started this
podcast you know nobody knew what
direction we were going with this thing
we just came on here we told calmly
stories you told whatever for me it was
opening up about my life it was being
vulnerable telling the story about mug
and a hooker and light no working on
fire and then you know things came out
and about four months ago something
happened that devastated me that was
then the last nail in the nailed many
coffins they fired a kid office Sam I
live because something he said an
episode 280 of some episode that
somebody dug up nap she has and he lost
his job and will happen and everything
happens for
Killam be a lot better off he'll move
together and they know prize being on
santanaya live so you know she was so
funny - he's amazing him stand up in the
last two weeks of hope I got a message I
got a message about six months ago from
somebody telling me something about
Senator and you know I got introduced by
Sen by another musician who knows sin
from somebody else and sin made the
headlines it's last week for sleeping
with underage girls you know I know that
he's taken down his website he's taken
down this Facebook page you know my
heart goes out to the victims of this
horrible thing I have a daughter I would
never wish afire and my heart also goes
out to sin because God knows Willie was
thinking we gotta say a prayer for him
whether or not who the [ __ ] now you know
as soon as I heard the story I thought
about Paris Hilton um David Letterman
tell the story on how she remembers
sneaking out of the window and she was
15 and gonna disclose when you're 15 and
you sneak out of a club you're not
sneaking out of a club to meet boys for
the 16 do you don't say yeah no totally
like when the deal when the and it all
starts at the doorman doorman no just
sixteen but yeah you're hot [ __ ] to the
musicians or the band or though was ever
in there so again my heart goes out to
both families you know sin for whatever
he did then he takes care of this
problem and to the family of the girls
in San Antonio or else they had if
you're offended that I had sit on my
apology to go to you and you guys know
that I don't really come up with
apologies let's let the have clear and
then we'll get to that number two
something else happened last week that
really got me thinking our friend Brad
Williams also has a podcast
the degenerates with him I've always I
always know Brad was afraid because I
get carried away those little midgets
they don't get confused you see a [ __ ]
know that he's got a black dick they
just have to know if I have a two-foot
dicks it's not a curse from God it's
just a [ __ ] of your lady and you want
a big dick and you don't want to cross
the line and you don't want your
property value to go down on your [ __ ]
okay so find yourself a nice looking
[ __ ] cuz that guy's got a dick today
he's gonna be taking that snake out of
his pants like a hose I'm saying I know
Brad
personally I've heard through the
grapevine he can wrap his dick around
your neck and choke you with it so don't
don't ever feel mad for jet digits a
[ __ ]
those [ __ ] are packing heat
between their legs and subdue you sure
you want the little [ __ ] them frame you
run while that three-foot dick is
[ __ ] anyway my boys mean then I don't
I don't know what happened with Brad
Williams aye I know he went on a podcast
six 14 years ago and told the story
about him and Carlos and they came up
with an apology was I there do I know I
don't need to be there to know I saw it
I saw women putting themselves in bad
positions I saw women come up to me and
say if you introduce me to such and such
I'll suck his dick I sucked your dick it
was it was a point where you feel badly
humanity you laugh and you feel bad for
you madly
you know Brad's on the [ __ ] end of the
stick right now again my heart goes out
to him my heart goes out to this poor
girl got [ __ ] by a [ __ ] this dark
because that's gotta be a [ __ ]
nightmare oppa yeah he wake up next to
somebody ugly it's one thing but waking
up to oppa looper loss idea it was funny
and I love Brad
I'm on the generous with I'm worried
they're gonna take a more [ __ ]
degenerate or something well and you
know I'm really worried about this but
this is just to let you know that this
is why I'm open with you people
I don't give a [ __ ] at this point my
life listen if you hear something if you
didn't hear from me
it didn't happen if that did happen I'll
tell you my side of the [ __ ] story
just see you [ __ ] know I said here's
all you people know is I'm not a me too
I mean I love looking at your titties
but I'm not at me too I love looking at
your ass I love women I love you to
death I mean last night there was a
point the economy store I had five
beautiful women around me and at one
time but I think a [ __ ] one who might
Felicia I had [ __ ] and he lead him in
I had [ __ ] Kate Quigley I had
light-skinned sister waitress at the
Comedy Store and that new little cute
one we were talking about something I'm
saying doesn't mean you're a meat or
write it just means you're talking to
people that's comedy mouse' that's the
great Tommy stores my family but you
know what man I'm just uh I'm happy that
I was always very vulnerable with you
guys from day one when I learned that
what you guys wanted to hear was truth
to it from the heart like people telling
you stories people letting you know that
it's okay to be human
mm-hmm I'm sick and tired of listening
to podcasts where they're above us ain't
nobody [ __ ] exam [ __ ] ball
the same and we all go through the same
struggles this guy drove 18 hours
between quit it's weird because when you
booked Buffalo in the old days Buffalo
had the funny bone she wouldn't book you
in Buffalo unless she could get you to
Cleveland impressed so when you called
it you got four weeks of work you got
Cleveland and it was back-to-back she
was cool about it right Sarah and I the
[ __ ] that she was she was cool about it
at that time so and I was a very little
asian [ __ ] it makes it so good-looking
but eva was [ __ ] and when she got
power she really started
[ __ ] I'll never forget her I
ever see outflow a thousand chopsticks
[Laughter]
I'll beat her with chopsticks I swear to
God
she was cruel she was very mean to you
very mentally very mean yeah if you
would have if you're a comic you wonder
what do I tell you what my pet peeve is
my pet peeve about comedians is [ __ ]
with their dream right that's my pet
peeve of a comedian I thought when
comedians hit me up hey I want to be in
your podcast
I don't string them all right you're in
no danger don't jump off a bridge and
get back to me I'm saying some guy
called me a couple weeks ago my friend
was on Rogen's podcast do you take a
behind your podcast do I know he's
escribe em well I was in the Army and
you I know you've been doing how many
six month way you bother me for me you
know go back to the army due to ten more
years to calm me and then get back to me
what do you want from me I can't help
you out yeah I'm working with guys up
here that I see busting their asses when
I put you in that chair it's because I
know you're busting your ass after every
night where the lead tells me Ryan
Sickler tells me I'm listening
and then I see you know I'm not putting
people in here to come in here and try
to pull the wool over their eyes there's
a thousand of those people out there
trying to pull the [ __ ] wall over
your sheriff for sure thousands of
people are looking looking over here
looking over here but nothing's happened
and it's the people who I am and you're
buying it but they ain't doing nothing
this cry right
I know [ __ ] they'll leave the
house at 6 o'clock don't walk back in
till 1:00 and gotta go to a job and
[ __ ] at 6 a.m. in the morning and at 5
o'clock they eat something do 10
push-ups and they're back waiting on
line you know I know a chiclet test for
open mikes the [ __ ] can't drive because
she has seizures and she takes a [ __ ]
Hoover everywhere yeah from do you
remember the other night you had to send
me money for a new beau who do you think
I was trying to help out I don't have
money for a [ __ ] over so I said come
up to the office I'll give you a few
bucks
how can I not you know she called me a
day and you wait two weeks they pay you
back I go listen don't worry about the
[ __ ]
money and they go call me she was [ __ ]
stuck yeah
a credit card and she's like I don't
know you well you know I don't know how
you if you could help me I said hold on
let me send an uber for you
you're not gonna in fact forget that do
you have any money issues I'm flat broke
I haven't eaten all day I said meet me
at the office I got a hi I gave her 50
bucks in fact I still owe you 20 bucks
that's amazing I remember last night I
mean I've been in those spots where it's
like you got a call up a buddy or
someone we all comes in it's like I did
it to 20 people so now when people call
me that Atomics mm-hmm that I see at the
store I tell people there's a thousand
people I pull aside and you listen you
need some you come see me I don't want
you sucking dick I don't want you doing
nothing you don't need to do you know if
you don't suck a dick for five you suck
my dick for three no yeah exactly
you gotta let these people know if they
need help man that's great that's why
I'm happy to calm these stores putting
funds together
I'm not saying give a comic two grand a
month I'm here this boy you know of
course I'm gonna get you out of a
[ __ ] bind if I know that you're
working if you're just trying to work me
for drug money yeah the fact last night
I bought somebody drugs well that's just
straight to the oh you can't worry about
a motor I gave you a lot of respect it's
Martin Luther King we thank you I don't
want to fight you
we need possible drugs it was a drug
dealer last night but I knew for 20
years I went up to him I said do you
have anything he goes yeah I go Bob I
put 60 bucks in his pocket I go go over
him they give that girl with G bunk she
came up to me when I got off stage and
hugged me she goes oh my god it was such
a price at the store has been like super
nice to like I'm not it's a love yeah
it's amazing you know last night I can't
tell you last night I almost crashed my
car driving to the store from the inside
the ad
when Ali Wong is supposed to go up at
9:15 you have a problem that schedule
ran from 9:15 to 11:30 each of those
guys have you saw them individually you
would have to pay $35 or more for sure
it went from her to Ron White to Daliya
to Anthony Jeselnik to Rogan to myself
the donnell rawlings
to Jeff Ross it's crazy
that's where it went things ended up it
mixed up and I had to bring up Ali and
we started dancing on stage next thing
you know I was like doing like the fan
I'm like oh my god how he's like I
tweeted this morning and thank them for
coming out you got any dates or anything
coming up anywhere anybody for fun oh
yeah I'm gonna be this weekend at the
dead crow comedy club in Wilmington
North Carolina and then next weekend I'm
gonna be at the comedy connection the
31st and the first in Rhode Island
problems yeah you have Lyman yep both
places for you brother
thank you you got a website now I'm just
doing it all on a [ __ ] Instagram dude
I don't even have a website yes people
are finding me though and buying tickets
and [ __ ] so I know that I gotta get it
I'm just bad at money and you know get
together I'm gonna be doing one soon on
your mom's house Network I'm working on
all the other ones though dr. drew honey
do your mom's house and I'm gonna be
starting mind pretty soon as well
hopefully like I told you told dr. drew
I'll do the podcast but it brings up
Lana Turner I got a break as guys I want
to thank you guys for being part of a
great [ __ ] family don't forget Friday
night no Saturday night there's a few
tickets left Atlanta at the Tabernacle
there might be so little tickets I don't
know what the [ __ ] they are do what you
need to do and February 13 14 and 15 st.
Valentine's Day I will be at the Tempe
improv tickets to go on quick
and we're gonna have a great time
Valentine's Day bring a condom and [ __ ]
bring a condom night the [ __ ] thing
have you been a condom I'll give you a
free per edible Oh something like that
but you gotta eat it with you got 800
condoms yeah yeah its condom night we'll
give them out to [ __ ] junkies or
thanks comics that wanna stuff things in
their [ __ ] anyway I love you guys
with all my heart real quick let me talk
to you about two of my favorite [ __ ]
companies first of all I can't tell you
how excited I am with butcher-block I
really [ __ ] was butcher box you know
I see these people on Jenny Craig in
that Malou Cruz [ __ ] but when I went to
my brother-in-law's and Kentucky I saw
he had a freezer in the end he would go
somewhere where they would send you
steaks pre-ordered advised him to the
[ __ ] every six months he said he knows
I won't buy deeper I buy enough to what
I know I save a little money and I just
buy a half a cow and he get steaks rib
eyes a meat low he gets it all out at me
local Kyle doesn't have a meat loaf you
know he gets the sirloin sirloin he gets
different parts of it night when my
agent called me about this I went on
their website and I read what they had
and I said send me a box and hey the
proof is in the [ __ ] pudding
so I'm very very very impressed with
butcher box I mean like I said earlier
they ship frozen and vacuum sealed food
so it arrives at your door fresh as a
[ __ ] daisy both the butcher box is a
subscription service that sends you nine
to eleven pounds of high-quality you
mainly raised me every month do you
understand me I'm talking about
free-range chicken heritage port
wild-caught salmon or you could pick one
of the curated collections on that
butcher box do all the work for you you
can customize every order with healthy
high quality meats like grass-fed beef
you
Sammy free-range chicken the Heritage
forth I myself had the salmon last night
it was [ __ ] delicious my wife made a
whole lemon sauce
she made some little red potatoes with
it and it rocked my [ __ ] world I will
let you know how the steak is in a few
days I believe come over to pick up a
few things what I want you to do is this
right now just gonna butcher box see
what they have to offer okay put
together a package give them a chance
Columbus dead listen this is what you
get from the church if you go through us
we're gonna give you free wings free
chicken wings for the life of your
subscription that's three pounds of
wings and every box forever think about
that every month you gonna have three
pounds of wings in there you hire some
of your neighbors to come over and cut
them up I don't like cutting the [ __ ]
wing you're [ __ ] rhythm you get
yourself a nice and walk my girlfriend
from Buffalo you still walk them yeah
that's how you do them then you shake
them up nice but let me tell you
something everybody likes a great way
what are you gonna do for the Superbowl
what are you thinking about
I'll miss you [ __ ] I come here Superbowl
I hit nobody in Kansas City Thomas and
well sampling to score but all those
[ __ ] I have a fruitcake but listen to
me the big game is around the corner you
these savages they're gonna be tearing
through your refrigerator forget that
stuff how you gonna feed these people
with a bowl of potato chips and [ __ ]
veggie plate I gotta sit there and smell
that broccoli I think it's [ __ ] feet
well forget about its butcher box so
right now right now butcher box
although special offer is free wings for
the life of your subscription that's
three pounds of wings and every box
forever plus you get twenty bucks off
your first box and free shipping in the
lower 48 just go to butcher box comm
slash Church and use promo code Church
had checked out the other company I
loved
why because they save your time they
save you money and they just save you
addicts I don't even do a resume look at
it through crystal ball forget about
that that's a zip recruiter comes in
it's a new year it's the year of the big
of your Chinese the perfect opportunity
to take your business to the next level
by hiring the right people but finding
qualified candidates is a challenge half
these people are [ __ ] stupid not ah
zip recruit calm slash Church makes it
very easy Joey why why does it recruiter
send your job to a hundred of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there right with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans through
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and invite them to
apply to your job as application comes
in zip recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never ever ever ever make miss a great
match zip recruit is so effective let me
tell you something that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruit it get
a quality candidate but then the first
day that's time that's saving your money
that's saving you the number one thing
aggravation do me a favor let's cut this
out grab a pen you're gonna go to an
exclusive web address zip recruiter
dot-com slash Church the zip recruiter
you ready zip Zi be recruiter our EC Rui
dr.com Church for another you stupid
people CH you are CH that zip recruiter
coms last Church zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire I want to welcome
butcher box I want to give a shout out
to zip recruiter but most importantly I
want to thank you [ __ ] savages fathom
my back I will see you saturday night
ready to [ __ ] rock in Atlanta I'm
ready to rip somebody's heart out I did
two spots last night in the store just
getting [ __ ] fired up
the one joke ate the bag of dicks but
the other ones on point you gotta love
it I promise you this I love your
[ __ ] wrong my heart remember
the song of the day out of respect for
Buffalo is you and I actually showing up
but what's the other one he did super
freak nah nah [ __ ] that [ __ ] it's either
UI or 69 times area 69 times Letterman I
haven't seen anything he kept doing 69
he sat down let him look the Rick James
and said is that off your Christmas
albums I love you [ __ ] to stay
black give it a whirl I'll see you
[ __ ] got land a Saturday night
or in Tempe Valentine's Day weekend kick
that [ __ ] Amelie